[Musique]
le journal du dimanche qui révèle que
150 quartier sous l'emprise de l'islam
radical
une jeune fille mila qui est menacée par
les plus fanatiques et abandonné par les
plus lâches mais moi j'ai pas envie de
faire partie de ceux qui compte
transmettre à nos enfants un pays
fragmenté
ça suffit il faut désigner l'adversaire
l'adversaire c'est l'islam politique
dans notre pays on a droit de critiquer
toutes les religions vous croyez que
quand sur france inter il ya eu ces
propos qui ont été tenus par l'humoriste
n'a du coup pas de manière spontanée
champions autour de jésus d'une
vulgarité
je considère que il est nul et qui la
zéro talent mais nous sommes en france
on a le droit de critiquer les religions
je me suis longtemps demandé
effectivement où étaient les grandes
voix de la gauche ont été les grandes
voix des féministes qu'on a très très
peu entendu ici c'est la france ceux qui
ne veulent pas vivre avec notre mode de
vie le respect de nos lois
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
est bien doivent partir à la cité cette
valeur fondamentale conquise de haute
lutte par nos aînés est aujourd'hui
abîmées dans nos hôpitaux dans nos
écoles dans nos territoires avec des
pratiques communautaires de plus en plus
lourdes violents eh bien nous nous avons
des propositions peu qu'ils pratiquent
un islam parfaitement compatible avec la
république et à fait servir une majorité
exactement
tous les sondages le montrent eh bien je
pense que ils ne doivent pas accepter
l'amalgamé pour ne pas accepter
l'amalgamme il faut désigner justement
ce qu'ils sont en train de radicaliser
les esprits nos pays est fracturée
commune est aujourd'hui c'est parce que
ce ton méprisant pédagogistes en
permanence qui consiste à dire au fond
en avez raison mais vous les français
vous n'avez rien compris c'est devenu
insupportable pour nos concitoyens
à nous de construire une troisième voie
une alternative celle que les français
attendent dire celles dont un débat
profond apaisé serein mais déterminé
notamment sur la question du financement
et de l' équilibre du régime de la seule
alternative crédible et républicaine à
la politique d' emmanuel macron sur la
question des retraites sur la question
du travail et du pouvoir d'achat
mais la réconciliation des territoires
de la laïcité
les républicains des christian jacob
possible
[Musique]